[Musique]
je n'ai pas à cette toile
en plus mon bassin est trop étroit et à
cause de ça mon bébé est né prématuré
bref je suis humaine et mon bébé n'a pas
la capacité musculaire pour s'accrocher
notre absence de fourrure n'est
peut-être pas si dérangeantes
finalement pour commencer je vais faire
appel à votre mémoire
avez vous en tête les nombreuses
demandes de vos enfants pour que vous
les portiers vous rappelez vous du
nombre d'heures passées à vous demander
quand votre chérubin s'endormirait enfin
et avez vous en tête les conseils que
l'on vous donner et peut-être même ce
que vous donnez à votre tour
oh mais laisse la pleurer elle finira
bien par t'endormir ou encore arrêt de
la porte et c'est vraiment un caprice sa
tord le ventre des parents d'entendre ce
genre de choses et on se dit que c'est
difficile de laisser pleurer son enfant
pour son bien qu'on le gâte avec notre
amour et colgate avec notre amour et
qu'on lui donne de mauvaises habitudes
si je vous disais qu'une autre voie est
possible
pas un chemin de traverse non mais un
chemin rempli de tranquillité si je vous
disais qu'on peut être jeunes parents
tout en étant zen et en ayant confiance
en soi vous êtes but hâtif et vous avez
raison je vais pas vous mentir je vais
même m'a même pas prétendre qu'on puisse
être bien coiffée puisque j'ai passé 16
mois avec un chignon avant de prendre
une décision plutôt radicale alors c'est
vrai c'est une inconnue autant physique
émotionnel est ce que je vous propose
c'est partir sur la parentalité par un
autre bouffe sur les voies de l'origine
notre espèce homo sapiens il ya 1,8
million d'années
je ne vous apprends rien en vous disant
que l'humain est un mammifère
nous avons des saints un utérus les
principaux attributs sont là mais nous
sommes sacrément différent des autres
mammifères
voyez comme le poulain gambade quelques
heures après sa naissance
et comme les chatons naissent avec les
yeux les conduits auditifs clos et pas
reportée afin de se tenir chaud
tous sont des mammifères mais avec des
modes d'adaptation à l'environnement
très différents et c'est sur cette
divergence qui engendre des besoins et
des attitudes spécifique du bébé humain
la bipédie implique que nous ayons un
bassin ont relativement étroit la
gestation doit être suffisamment courte
pour que la tête passe sans encombre et
heureusement qu'elle est souple mais
suffisamment longue pour que bébé soit
viable
l'humain n'est donc prématuré dans ce
développement et vous devez savoir que
son évolution n'est pas la plus rapide
du règne animal
d'ailleurs la constitution du bébé
humain n'a pas beaucoup évolué depuis
l'origine de notre espèce
puisque la gestation dure environ neuf
mois quand tout se passe bien mais ce
qui nous différencie des autres
mammifères
c'est le fait que notre cerveau à la
naissance nous développer qu'à 23 %
après 1 an
le cerveau a doublé de volume et à 3 ans
il atteint 90% de sa taille adulte
comparativement les autres mammifères
viennent au monde avec un cerveau des
blancs paix à 80 % et 40 % pour les
chimpanzés qui sont plus proches de nous
ça veut dire qu'il faut beaucoup de
temps aux bébés humains pour acquérir
certaines compétences motrices et
cognitives et pendant tout ce temps là
il est très dépendant et passifs un peu
moins sage là
mais ça veut dire que le porter dans un
environnement hostile et l unique
solution pour le protéger et comme ce
n'est pas hostile
on va pour la poser des stops la caisse
cascades tout ça voilà donc dans un
environnement hostile était la seule
solution pour les protéger était de les
porter puisqu'à l'époque nous étions
nomades la sédentarité nautique est très
récente
d'ailleurs bernard azen stein un
biologiste et comportementaliste
allemand a classifié l'humain comme
espèce porté au même titre que les
marsupiaux où les primates
c'est donc le corps qui devient le nid
capables de pourvoir à tous les besoins
vous ne pensez pas être capable de
pourvoir à tous les besoins d'un humain
par votre propre corps et pourtant vous
avez des saints pour le nourrir de la
chaleur on la réchauffer et votre
attention pour le rassurer
le bébé humain n'a pas besoin de
beaucoup plus pour se développer
cette première année et comme une
grossesse extra-utérine en fait et elle
lui permettra d'accéder à des
compétences motrices et cognitives
comparable à nos congénères hominidés
que sont les gorilles les chimpanzés et
les orangs outans à la naissance
ne vous offusquez pas d'être comparé à
des primates
nous avons quelque chose de plus et
c'est l'ampleur de notre cortex
préfrontal dans cette zone siège de
nombreuses facultés dont le raisonnement
logique mais aussi la gestion
émotionnelle et la gestion des
comportements sociaux
c'est pour cette raison que jusqu'à
l'âge de 5 ou 6 ans la gestion de des
événements quotidiens est très compliqué
les enfants ne sont pas ne viennent pas
au monde avec un mode d'emploi
vous le savez tous et s'approche
certains dans un profond mal être et à
l'offre de ce mal-être la dépression
post partum
heureusement
il ya des possibilités pour aller contre
ça pour se sentir vraiment mieux et pour
se faciliter la vie et ce n'est pas un
mode d'emploi mais un moyen
un mode d'action c'est encore plus
efficace et c'est le portage le portage
n'est pas qu'un moyen
c'est aussi une façon de vivre au
quotidien avec son enfant et louvre les
voies d'une communication corporels dans
toutes les circonstances de la vie
quotidienne on peut travailler de chez
soi
allez un musée on peut faire ses courses
et aller aux toilettes en ayant un
enfant en portage croyais en mes seize
mois d'expérience mais on peut se
demander pourquoi s'engager dans un tel
choix assez envahissant parce qu' on
cherche leur sérénité mais par là la
nôtre aussi porter c'est avoir un enfant
qui est calme et qui pleure très peu
parce qu'il est rassuré par le corps
portait c'est aussi avoir savoir en
quelques instants
quand un enfant à fin août quand il a
trop chaud portée c'est permettre aux
bébés de se développer de manière
optimale tant au niveau de son crâne que
de sa posture que de sa régulation
émotionnelle est porté c'est permettre à
l'enfant de se faire confiance pour son
sommeil il peut s'endormir quand il en
ressent le besoin et on ne se tracasse
pas de savoir si on doit le déposer et
s'il va se réveiller parce que en ayant
les deux mains libres on peut vaquer à
ses occupations et même partir se
promener garde d'un enfant tout contre
eux soit permet de se sentir efficace
auprès de lui et lui évite bien des
désagréments et le tout dans un
minimalisme exceptionnel il suffit d'un
bout de tissu et d'un corps humain
d'ailleurs cet amour censé être
inconditionnel
par rapport aux nouveaux venus c'est une
vraie découverte et personne ne peut
savoir comment il va réagir face à un
nouveau né
ce que je peux vous assurer c'est
qu'avoir un enfant portage ne laisse pas
indifférent pour la simple et bonne
raison que cela stimule l'ocytocine chez
le porteur et l'ocytocine agit dans
l'établissement des liens affectifs
ce que je vous raconte la gelée vécu
mais ce n'est pas mon témoignage
anecdotique qui fait foi
tous ces constats ont été effectués par
la recherche scientifique et
prioritairement le bébé humain a besoin
de contacts proximo et de lien
émotionnel pour se développer de façon
optimale la culture la société
les bébés eux s'en fiche complètement la
poussette n'a que trois cycles
d'existence la physiologie du nouveau né
n'a pas évolué selon les coutumes
sociales
il reste dans ce même état de dépendance
extrême extrême créneau craignant
l'environnement qu'il découvre à peine
et cherchant à se rassurer parce qu'il
connaît in utero le mouvement de sa mère
les bruits du coeur la position foetale
et un contact contenant portait était de
tout temps la manière utilisée pour que
les bébés puisse être réconfortés
pendant que leurs mères reprenaient
leurs activités mais à l'heure actuelle
c'est aussi un moyen qu'ont les
partenaires et les autres membres de
l'entourage de faire participer les
enfants à la vie quotidienne tout en
établissant des liens affectifs
alors c'est vrai aujourd'hui
vous n'avez peut-être pas l'occasion
plus l'occasion de porter des enfants
mais vous pouvez ressentir chaque jour
l'importance du contact
prenez quelques instants pour vous
remémorer les sensations quand vous vous
étendez près d'un être cher ou quand
vous serrez quelqu'un dans vos bras vous
démontrez votre affection et vous vous
rechargez par la même occasion la vie
émotionnelle au cours de la vie de cours
de la vie l'évolution émotionnel au
cours de la vie ne s'arrête jamais
aujourd'hui vous êtes ici est ce que
vous entendez fera peut être changer
votre perspective sur le monde vous
embarquer dans une nouvelle expérience
et peut-être que mon intervention aura
faire remonter des souvenirs tendres ou
compliqué est ce que je vous souhaite
c'est que vous trouviez des bras pour
accueillir vos émotions que l'homme
comme cela devrait être le cas depuis
votre naissance le portage implique de
l'empathie et la volonté de comprendre
les besoins physiologiques des bébés il
permet de s'ancrer dans l'instant
présent
mais aussi d'offrir inestimable du temps
et de la présence entière les enfants
ainsi accompagner peuvent ainsi entrer
plus facilement en empathie avec autrui
par la suite ils peuvent questionner
leurs besoins et exprimé les leurs avec
beaucoup plus d'authenticité à leur
niveau ils participeront à l'élaboration
d'un monde bienveillant merci de votre
écoute et portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]